hello there look at these
objects right here what if i told you
that i'm going to give you a bunch of
pictures of these objects from
different sides and what you have to do
is you have to come up with a system
that generates me
the picture as if the object was viewed
from any
direction so something like this
right any direction you can get me a
picture of that object from just
a few input pictures this is a pretty
daunting task specifically look at the
ship
for example right here you can see in
the water there's
specularities that only appear if you
view it from a very particular
angle right also the drum kit you see
that
the microphone on the left it has very
specific uh
structure to it so this is not at all
like a trivial task um
there there's very there's very
uh very intricate things here and this
not only with toy data but here you can
see
uh real world scenes so this isn't some
kind of abstract thing
you can actually use this in the real
world
now don't look at these things too long
they tend to make me
dizzy but that's ultimately the goal
input a few pictures and then being able
to synthesize
any kind of view so the paper we're
going to look at
it's a bit of an older paper but i think
it's pretty cool
and it's relevant and there is a bunch
of follow-up work
to this this is very popular right now
this is the paper introducing nerf
representing scenes as neural radiance
fields
for view synthesis and it's by ben
mil sorry ben mildenhall pratul p
srinivasan
matthew tanchik jonathan t baron ravi
rama murthy
and ren eng this
as you can see the task is called view
synthesis
and what you can do with with view
or with this paper specifically is
you can it can also it takes into
account
your viewing direction which gives a
much more realistic impression
we've already seen this with kind of the
the lighting here
but in order to really show you this on
the left you're
going to see this novel view that is
rendered
and on the right it's sort of like a
fake thing that you couldn't do in
reality
but what we're going to do is we're
going to keep
the camera at the same position but
we're going to tell the scene
that the camera is at a like switching
around
and that makes you able to see just how
different
a pic like a room can look like if
viewed from different directions so the
right one is really
kind of physically impossible it's just
meant to show you
how different things look differently if
they think they are viewed from a
different direction
right so the same thing here
and it just looks amazing
what you get automatically out of the
systems are depth maps
um these are notoriously hard to get
especially for
complex scenes such as this one uh
also this one right here it's it's very
complex and
it handles it fairly well sorry
you can even do something like ar um
right here since you now have a
representation
that tells you how far everything is
away and you have it from different
views
you can see uh yeah and you can even get
meshes so i should be able to
move that around here this is now a mesh
it's not only view synthesis
but you can actually fill out the voxels
which is a slightly different task
and if you have pictures from all around
you can synthesize kind of any view
in between as you can see right here
uh we're gonna switch away from the
fancy videos to
the paper now the special thing about
this paper and this
is it's in the spirit of something like
sirens so sirens we've
i've made a video about it and the
special thing right here is it
uses deep learning in a little bit of a
different way than we would normally
use it so first of all what does the
abstract say
we present a novel sorry a method but it
is novel
that achieves state-of-the-art results
for synthesizing novel views of complex
scenes by optimizing
an underlying continuous volumetric
scene function
using a sparse set of input views so
the task description is the view
synthesis right
synthesizing novel views also you're
given a sparse set of input views so
you're given
you have a scene let's say you have a
tree or something like this so here's a
tree
i know beautiful and you're given a
bunch of images
so maybe someone you know stood here
and took a picture so the picture kind
of views in
in this direction it pictures depicts
the tree and someone stood here
and took a picture of the same tree
maybe the same person
someone flew up here took a picture of
that tree so you get a bunch of those
maybe you get 20 or something
around the tree maybe more maybe less
so from these pictures you want to build
a thing that can
generate any view from anywhere okay
and the way they do it is by optimizing
an underlying continuous volumetric
scene
function this is a cryptic
um way but it goes
along the direction of the sirens and
kind of a bigger
trend in i think in the ei in these in
these neural rendering papers and so on
which is that we want to over fit
a neural network to a single data point
this is really different from classic
deep learning if you know
if you ask someone how would you go
about this problem with deep learning
what they would tell you is
okay i need a data set i need a data set
of
these you know different scenes and the
input
and i have my x and my y so the input x
is going to be
always like you know 30 images
of a scene and y is going to be the
scene itself
or what not like the tree or the mesh of
the tree or something like this
and i need this many many times so
i need a data set with 30 images
of i don't know a
a house and the the why
is the house and so on so that's my
training data set then in my test data
set
it can be something else right
so it can be things that i now uh want
to test
however in this particular case this is
not the case
here the it is one
neural network that is fit to one scene
so what we have is a neural network
that has a bunch of layers
and all the neural network cares about
is this particular scene right
if we want to render a new scene we take
a new neural network
that's what i mean we over fit a single
neural network
to this particular scene we use the 30
images or so we got
to train to completely over fit this
neural network
and the goal is going to be that the
tree itself
like the scene itself is going to be
in the weights of this neural network so
the weights of the neural network now
represent the scene and this has various
advantages right if the
we already saw this with the sirens that
very often this is a much much better
representation
more compact representation of the
entire mesh than
a any other way like if you store it in
voxels or something
but i hope this is a bit clear now of
course the
question is what's the input and what's
the output
of this neural network so the input is
the following imagine you have a
coordinate system
here so you get you get a coordinate
system
x y and z
okay and the neural network gets two
things as an input it gets as an input a
position
in that coordinate system which we call
we call x and x is a
it's actually x y z is a three
dimensional vector right
for example right here this is
our x now and also we get
an d which is a viewing direction
okay so the for example if my camera is
the top camera right here
the viewing direction would be um
this ray here well everything's orange
i'm gonna make that blue so the viewing
direction
d would be that okay so the the angle
here we care about the angle um
it's actually two angles you need to
describe this viewing direction
so a position and the viewing direction
and the output of the neural network
what does it output the output of the
neural network is going to be
a color c like what color
is at that particular location and the
density
is there even something at that
particular location
right so the density tells you whether
there is something or not and
if there is something the color tells
you what color it is
all right this is a really different way
i want to stress that again of using
neural networks there's no longer images
going in
and you know something coming out what
goes in is a position
and a direction so you ask the neural
network hey neural network
you in your entirety you
represent this scene you represent
if you're trained well if you're over
fit well you're you're over fit
on the tree now i want to know at the
particular location
in this scene viewed from a particular
angle what am i going to see so on this
picture right here i'm wondering
for this pixel if i send array to this
location what am i going to see
and the network will tell you you're
probably not going to see anything
because there's nothing there or if
there is something there you're going to
see
the color i don't know red
okay so how from this
you can pretty easily get a picture
namely if i have
my frame of the picture for each pixel i
need to send a
ray through the scene so i send array
through the scene
and what i need to do is i need simply
need to query this model
at each location so here here here here
here
here here and so on at each location
i will ask the neural network is there
something there
and if there is what kind of color am i
gonna what am i gonna see
and what you'll get is a bit of a curve
thank you is a bit of a curve um
so if here is your your 0
and you send the ray out into the scene
and this is the density
going up they have these graphs in the
paper by the way i'm not
i'm i'm not smart enough to come up with
them by myself
but they say well maybe at the beginning
you're not going to see anything
because there's nothing there but then
you know at some point
you're going to see something there is
something there you get you hit the tree
right and you're inside the tree and
then you're out of the tree again
okay at the same time at every point it
gives you
color now here uh it actually doesn't
matter what the color is
it will still output a color but it
doesn't matter and here it's going to
say
green right it's going to say at every
point here is going to say green
green green green
and here i guess it doesn't matter it's
probably going to say green as well
but in any case what you can now do is
you can simply look at
where do i hit the first time the object
which is here right when the density
goes up
and what color is there and now i know
what i need to render at that particular
pixel
now you can simply do this for all
pixels and
you got yourself an image and the neural
network is powerful enough
that for the same location you can see
this right here
it can give you different results
depending on the different viewing
directions
so that makes it such that it can
kind of depend on where you view it from
it can capture these lighting effects
these these
reflections and also it can capture
uh transparency because imagine you have
a curve
that is not as clear as this one but you
have a curve that is something like
here so here is a one wall of a glass
and here is another wall of the glass
and they go up in density but
they're not fully dense right and the
front of the glass is maybe
blue and the back of the glass is red
and now if you integrate your ray along
this
uh and you you integrate weighted by the
density
you're going to get a mixture of you
know preferably blue
because that's in the front but also a
little bit of red right you can see that
like if a ray goes through here you can
handle
transparency and so this is a really
powerful model um right here
and again there's no need for a data set
other than the date the scene that is
right in front of you
so the goal is going to be that if in
the future
we want to you know we want to make
augmented reality applications we want
to make games and so on
you are not actually going to store a
mesh or kind of a voxel grid
of some scene what you're going to store
is a neural network
that can be queried from anywhere you
want to look
at the scene and the neural network will
tell you what you're going to see
it just happens that these things work
extraordinarily well
here's the process again the task you
get a set of input images
right here you
want to find out where they're taken
from so for each input image
you need to determine where was the
camera and in which direction did it
look this is this is a known problem
you can so all these kind of classic
also structure from motion
slam and so on they need to determine
the camera positions uh
from the pictures and so that that's a
that's a thing you can take from
existing research and then you want to
render the new
views and yeah
here is i think where they get into it
where
oh this is yeah we represent they say
a continuous scene as a 5d vector valued
function
and this the vector function is going to
be a neural network
it has a five-dimensional input and it
has
a the output is going to be a color
which is three dimensions and a density
which is
one dimension okay so the input is a 3d
location and a 2d viewing direction
and the output is a color and a
volume density so in practice
we express direction as a 3d cartesian
unit vector
and they say we approximate this
continuous 5d scene representation
with an mlp network so the network
as we said this is the input this is the
output
and we optimize its weights to map
from each input 5d coordinate to its
corresponding
volume density and directional immediate
color
now the the only question is of course
we have these images we don't actually
we don't actually have
we don't actually have the as a training
set
kind of the the the densities at that
place
so everything needs to be sort of
grounded into the images
that we have now luckily the whole
process that i've described here which
you see again here so if you want to
render an image
you take an image you pick a pixel you
shoot a ray
and you sample along the ray and you ask
your network what's there the network
will tell you
if there's something there and if so
what color
you're going to see the density over
time
and then you can render an image now you
if if you already have an image right
which is we are given
a set of these images um if you already
have one
you can now calculate a loss namely what
do i see and what does the network tell
me
i should see right if the network is not
trained yet that's going to be a pretty
big loss
and if you make the loss as something
differentiable then this whole
process is in fact differentiable that's
the next cool thing about this the whole
process of
sending the array um sampling that
position
integrating over it and at the end
coming up with a pixel color
that is a differentiable process if of
course
if you do it correctly but that means
we can use those 30 images or 50 or
whatever we have
in order to construct a big loss right
every
ray so every pixel in
every picture that we have defines array
so every
ray essentially is a data point that we
can fit to so at the end we get a pretty
sizable
data set for the network which is going
to be
number of pixels times number of
pictures
however again it is a different problem
than
having a data set of many of these
scenes
so the whole process is differentiable
and that means you can just
fit the neural network to this scene you
overfit it to these 30 images that you
have
and that's going to be your network and
this network
then is going to represent the scene
in its weights so the weights
are the scene at the end
uh there is a bit of a so there are lots
of engineering tricks here
uh so for example we encourage the
representation to be
multi-view consistent by restricting the
network to predict the volume density as
a function of
only the location x while allowing the
rgb color to be predicted as a function
of both location
and viewing direction so the reasoning
here is that
the the volume density is not dependent
on the direction like either
even if something is kind of transparent
it's going to be
transparent it's going to be the same
transparency in
from different direction there's only
very limited amount of materials
where that is not the case right so as a
simplifying concept we're going to see
the transparency
of the object is always the same which
is kind of
where stuff is is independent of where
you look from it's only
how stuff looks uh that is dependent so
the rgb
color is going to be a function of
both location and viewing direction
and what they do is essentially so they
input
x um right here they
so the the location they yank this
through a network they get out two
things so they
first get out this density and they also
get out a hidden representation
that hidden representation they then
concatenate with the viewing direction
and that goes through another stack of
layers
in order to give them the color
okay i think it's also you know you
could do
something with a transformer here and
some causal masking
though i'm pretty sure someone has
already done this given that the paper
is almost
ancient at one year of age
in the machine learning world that's
really old
so exactly so this is the formula
for new for rendering this is a
technique called
volume rendering with radiance fields so
if you have a radiance field a radiance
field is a function
that tells you exactly what we train a
neural network to do namely you know
if i look from here and i look at that
point what do i see
what you want to do is you want to send
a ray through
the scene and you want to integrate
along that race you have kind of a
forebound and a near bound
and you want to integrate from the near
bound to the far
bound so that means you send the ray
through the thing you want to integrate
um this thing this t
thing right here that tells you you can
see the density is in here along the ray
from the beginning to the point where
you are
that is the probability that the ray
doesn't hit anything
right it's the probability that the ray
goes on
through that room basically it's the
probability of empty space
um so or you know the inverse of that
like
this distinguishes whether there is
something or not whether the array
continues
up until the point t or not so you have
whether or not the ray is actually at
that particular point
how dense that particular point is so
how much
stuff there is in terms of um
occludence for your ray so if this is
high
your ray is going to stop and you're
going to adopt the color that is there
you can see it's this is multiplied by
the color
at that particular place so you send the
array
and as soon as your system determine you
know there's something here
you're going to since this is multiplied
the density is multiplied by the color
your your ray is going to adopt the
color
of whatever is there and then after that
this quantity here is going to be small
because this quantity is
again an inner integral that tells you
whether or not the ray
even reaches that location so the ray
reaches the first location
at which point it's going to adopt the
color and after that
the it even though there is stuff right
even though the density is high
the ray is not reaching it so the whole
formula captures all of this and
as we said with a bit of nuance it like
if this is not always 0 1 it can handle
transparency
as well and here they demonstrate again
from the scene so you have two different
points in the same scene
but viewed from different locations and
on the right they show you
this is all the same point in the scene
but the circle
represents kind of different angles at
which you can view it
from and you can see that the color is
really different depending on the angle
where you look from there are
what do we have here there are a lot of
tricks oh yeah so they
they approximate the integral with like
quadrature
um which also has existed and
they have a bunch of tricks so the first
trick to really get this to work
is a novel like not a novel but kind of
the employment of a positional encoding
now the positional coding is not the
same as you might know it from
transformers or something the positional
encoding here
it simply means that you send the input
data point
which is this thing right here xyz theta
five greek letter
um you send that
to a higher dimensional space right in a
very
deterministic way so if you have these
low dimensional input
and especially if you want to represent
this this is really fine structure
right here you can see that um
that this this stuff right here it's
it's quite fine-grained
okay and so you need a way
to handle fine differences between
things but you also need a way to handle
you know course differences and just
a single floating point number probably
isn't going to do it for a continuous
function like this
so what you do is you send this to a
higher
dimensionality with these positional
encodings that we know from transformers
so these encodings right here they will
send
so what you do and so in my video on
attention is all you need i explain
those
in detail but you construct a hierarchy
of sine waves or like sine and cosine
waves but
we can we can just do it with with sine
waves so the the lowest hierarchy is
like
this and then the next thing in the
hierarchy would be like
double as fast and then the next thing
well this is four times as fast isn't it
well you get the point right it's uh so
i need
up down wow and then
up down up down up this is not even a
sine wave
but but you i hope you get the point and
then
um
you want to take a look for example your
x you
take your x you put it here like okay
x is so this is like uh negative i think
they go from negative one to one the
coordinates they have and
your high dimensional output is going to
be um
you know this point this point this
point and this point in the in their
respective
coordinate systems right so that's
you can what this does is you can still
clearly identify every point here in
fact
yeah you can you can identify every
single point
in your input space by
you know looking at looking at the
combination
of where it is in these sine waves but
it gives the network
a better chance to focus for example on
details if it wants to focus on details
is going to look at this scale right
here because tiny changes in
the underlying x is going to result in a
large change in this feature if you want
to focus on coarse grain stuff
then you look at this where you can you
know you have to move pretty far
to have a change whereas if you look at
this scale
for coarse grained things it means
almost nothing
because you know if you
you want to make little difference
between these two things if you look at
coarse grained
structure but they have as you can see
like there's a lot of difference between
those like this maybe zero and this is
maybe negative one
however um
if you look at the two data points right
here oh
sorry about that so the same let's say
the orange distance and the blue
distance
you can see that the two aren't so
different in this representation so it
gives the network the choice
at which scale it wants to look at for
particular
positions so ultimately you're going to
map
this five-dimensional vector into a
higher dimensional vector and they
consider like
10 10 layers or four layers
of these how many of these different
sine way and cosine waves they construct
so again they call it positional cutting
they say this is referred to as a
positional encoding
however transformers use it for a
different goal of providing discrete
representations as input to an
architecture
yada yada in contrast we use these
functions to map continuous input
coordinates into a higher dimensional
space
to enable enable our n mlp
to more easily approximate a higher
frequency functions
the second thing they do is they do
hierarchical volume sampling so when we
said
i send a ray through the scene and then
i sample
along this either would take a lot of
time
or um it would
not be accurate enough so what they do
is they have actually two
layers of neural network one they call a
course
and one they call a fine and as
i understand it here is array they first
sample with the coarse one
at rather coarse locations
and then they use that to evaluate where
they should sample more
let's say this thing right here has a
real high density in the course
network they then sample around that
a lot more maybe one here too but a lot
more you know sampling around
where the course network things the
important stuff is
they optimize both networks at the same
time
and that actually works out well
so here you see the loss the loss is a
combination now
of the course network and the fine grain
network and you need to optimize both
even though the final view is only going
to come
from the fine grain network right
you need to optimize both because the
core screen network
can tell you where the important stuff
is
so the results you have already seen
there are a bunch of
metrics that prove that this one
is really good and it can as you can see
like you can handle fine grain structure
right here in the microphone that others
can't
and it also so they say
it fits into a few so one neural network
of one scene fits into like a few
megabytes
and this is so it fits into five
and this is a lot better than things
that use like
voxel grid representations which um
i think this other thing they compare to
uses over 15
gigabytes for the same scene
which and this is interesting which is
even less memory than the input images
alone for a single scene from any of our
data sets
so this is really like it's it's really
it's even smaller than the
the pictures right so so even if you
maybe want to show this to another
human it'd be better you send the
train nerf than the pictures if space is
a
consideration though i don't know how
they measure the pictures like you can
probably compress
if it's different pictures from the same
scene
i guess there's some compression
potential if you want to transmit them
as opposed
never mind so they'd also do ablations
and the only downside here is that it
does take a long time to fit one of
these neural networks i
don't exactly remember where they say it
but they say
they calculate like oh here so it's not
too bad but the optimization for a
single scene typically take around
100 to 300k iterations to converge
on a single nvidia v100 gpu which is
about one to two
days so it's a single gpu so it is you
know
you don't need a data center for it uh
but you're gonna wait a while until you
train one
though you only need to train it once
and then you can render new views
as you please right so the idea i think
is going
to be that let's say you make a video
game or so
you're going to render this you know at
your servers then you transmit the
neural network
to the clients and the clients can just
render it out
right there and yeah
there's a bunch of results and a bunch
of ablations where they kind of leave
away different parts and they show that
especially kind of the positional
encodings i think this is the
positional encodings are really
important as you can see on the right
there is no positional encodings
the view dependence is also quite
important you see if there's no
view dependence as you can see here
you do get the fine grain structure
since you do have position encodings but
you don't get these
kind of light effects right this is this
thing here
is not a different color it's simply the
fact that the line
light shines on it and it's just not
there
here because you know all the network
can do is
output the same color for all directions
and most directions simply don't have
that
reflection all right so that is it
the code is available on this website
that i've showed you i'm certainly going
to link it
tell me what you think i think this is
pretty cool i know this has
given rise to a lot of work following up
on this i have
very little overview over what's going
on in the nerf
space but i think it's cool and i want
to dive deeper into it
thanks for being here bye-bye